we're gonna play our own fruity
detective game um with you both it's a
sense and edibility cute jane austen pun
there um with our foodie hour challenge
so we have our amazing foodie trophy at
stake here
and we need someone to host this game
[Applause]
all right you take it away okay okay so
first challenge okay this is gonna be a
test of your foodie knowledge your
senses and all of the things that you
know okay and there are things there are
three challenges and they're all
trending are you ready yes okay so the
first challenge is in the cup you can
you can look at it smell it then sip it
and write your answer on this board
and let me see and whoever's right will
get points toward this magnificent
trophy
go
see ludo took the he took the cup right
off
right english uh we i was gonna say in
front yeah
are we ready have any okay i'm gonna let
natasha go first what do we have natasha
cold mcdonald's coffee that's a song oh
no
called macdonald i think you're thinking
of something else darling
um it yeah
some icy coffee something iced tea
coffee so are you saying iced tea and
coffee that's not a thing in america oh
yeah it's not equestria so just a cold
coffee although with food trends you
never know so it's iced coffee yeah is
that your final answer yeah okay
true
iced coffee with lemonade oh
okay
in your glass is orange juice and
espresso oh
no you're not far she's the closest no
that's what i said so should we give her
a point we're going to give her a point
come on thank you thank you
yeah that's a trend
i'm gonna believe it or not this trends
popped up on tick tock people either
love it or hate it all right let's go
you ready for the next one
all right
put on your blindfolds please
blindfolds okay uh this is gonna test
your feel
and feel it then eat it then write down
your answer on the board we get to eat
it you get to eat it
no wait i mean we have to eat it
oh oh
it's tough right
garlic it sounds like it's something
that you would know right oh my god what
whoa huh
the blindfold is storing my equilibrium
off you okay
can i take observing fall right yes of
course
i'm just really i love being here okay
you ready you're very quick what is that
i'm sorry i don't know if i was supposed
to show well yeah you can show
okay fried cheese fried cheese
orange cheese orange fried orange cheese
yeah fried rum cheese
it's so much fun this is a new food
network show i think right here
yes i did not like it at all okay you
didn't like your first one you're a hard
customer yeah
fried chex mix with cheddar
i i don't know the answer
pasta chips
so it's pasta wow
pasta cheeks pasta cooked blanched right
there take a look and toss with olive
oil on a little parmesan this was a
tick-tock thing but it's good it's tasty
now okay so it's slightly cooked yes oh
it's actually cooked oh you bake it in
the fryer okay okay
oh wow
so i mean
this trend on tick tock you ready it got
1.1 billion tags
okay third challenge you're ready this
is fun okay
you have a candle in front of you
your job you are lighting it one of them
okay is a candle
uh actually and the two of them are a
candle and one is a cake so light what
you think is
who's who are you ready
so drew do you think this is a cake
or a candle cake
wow okay write it down oh sorry
ludo you're having a little trouble with
the lighting over there that's good so
you're just going to do one
yeah you need help ludo no sir
ghetto which means cake cake cake
mine's different
ludo hasn't even played this any of the
games right
[Applause]
all right so we have two winners
so
i'm giving it up to look uh to natasha
or
a let me award this beautiful
one
[Applause]
do i have shot check this at jfk yes yes
you need to
thank you natasha thank you thank you
well done
thank you
natasha
in the kitchen air thursday on tbs at 9
8 central it is so fun it is so good get
in that kitchen
[Music]